i will say i one of the things i think
that really struck me you know we meet
your character as of last week's episode
um
we get the sense i think of qazi's
relationship with maya right away and
how he really kind of feels like almost
her grounding energy or someone who can
level her out maybe when she's kind of
wants to charge ahead and take action um
so i'm curious were there ever any
conversations between you and alaqua
about how to play that dynamic on on
screen
yeah for sure we
were very blessed to have had a lot of
time to rehearse our scenes i mean i was
immeasurably
grateful for it because i had more time
to learn the sign language which um
which i was nervous about initially
because i wanted to you know
be proficient enough to
to make quasi-believable
fluent sign language
communicator and interpreter
but what it meant that we
was not another gift was that we got to
spend so much time together you know you
do usually get to rehearse a lot
on film or tv um
[Music]
so this was this was a real blessing and
it meant that we were able to discuss
the characters and their motivations and
it it is a
utterly intriguing relationship you know
they've been in each other's lives for a
long time and kazi's is there in the
karate class learning karate at the same
time as little maya
and so they have a relationship you know
a familial relationship
um and care very deeply about one
another
kazi
i suspect would have imagined himself in
a higher position in the organization
than
than maya
that has been his driving force all of
his life i'm not sure if it's been
maya's driving force all her life but
perhaps after the death of her father
she felt it useful to
to be in the organization and
use that that manpower to try and find
out who did this but it has always been
khalsi's driving force
and
so
from going from this familial
brother-sister
um set up
to then
feeling somewhat emasculated by
by maya taking the position that he
perhaps thinks is rightfully his we've
got a bit of conflict going on
and
whereas kazi was perhaps
able to in the past
calm
maya down and keep her level headed
because he's a very cool collected
cucumber like but she is extremely
reactive you know you saw that when she
goes for
for kate bishop like she's reactionary
and
impulsive and that's dangerous in an
organization like this that is criminal
on underbelly they should be keeping a
low profile you know
um but
mai is absolutely finding her voice in
this show
and i think her
her um
quest for revenge is unsatiable and
uh it'll be interesting to see if cause
he's able to do anything about that
i'm curious as well it what appealed
about the character to you in terms of
how he's presented on the page because
clearly you know he has a comics history
we're not really delving into that yet
it feels like the show is kind of
focusing more on the relationships and
kind of building him from the ground up
rather than being like here's this you
know here's this comics person that you
know so was was that it was that part of
the appeal or were there other
components as well
i mean the appeal was just
just i'd play anything i'll play
anything in this marvel world i'm such a
huge fan in any way and i didn't know
anything about this character when i was
auditioning for it i still knew very
little whenever i was cast to tell you
the truth but i had read the um the
fraction comics that the series is based
on
and yeah i found them very
compelling you know um super cool uh
brooding and sinister and sly and like
all of those quite heightened things
that we would associate with like a
villainous
character but
it's it's it's really wonderful how
marvel studios have managed to
take these villainous characters and
give them a lot more depth so there's a
there's a reason reason to be and
there's a reason to act in a certain way
and
and yeah we may not have um
explored fully
this this whole
um spectrum
um we're trying to figure out what these
motivations are and and where kazi has
come from and how he's found himself to
be in the position he's in
um and what truly drives him that's
something that i've loved exploring and
um
i i hope the you know the viewers enjoy
watching it unfold and it's and it's and
it's sort of slow beautiful way that
we're doing
um you have a great scene with jeremy
renner in this week's episode the scene
in the car you know it's very brief that
there's there's some great humor that
that gets to play out but i think that
we also see
a little bit of qazi starting to feel
conflicted um you know with his
dedication to maya and and
wanting to help her but then also
there's bigger picture um that's kind of
at stake so how is that going to play
out
um through the rest of the season i know
you probably can't say much but
well yeah you you just hit the nail in
the head that's exactly what's going on
you know kazi isn't as straightforward
as just bad guy and we'll do whatever he
wants to get to the top
um there clearly is
um a soul in there that has
some sense of empathy and responsibility
and loyalty and yeah he's utterly
conflicted with these two opposing
factors
um
you know um
it'll be interesting to see if he
manages to
choose one over the other is it
advantageous if he chooses one over the
other for his own personal gain or
um you know it's it'll be really
intriguing and interesting to see what
actually happens
uh i personally can't wait for the fans
to see what does happen um but thank you
again so much for taking the time to sit
and chat about the show congratulations
on on it finally being in the world and
uh and have a great day thanks so much
bye-bye
thanks bye
you